le Salon du livre d'élancour était de
retour pour sa 6e édition dimanche 10
décembre organisé par l'association Les
Amis du passé d'lancour il a rassemblé
75 auteurs au programme conférence
échange débat dédicace toujours avec un
but précis transmettre l'amour pour la
littérature le livre
estide à transmettre des savoirs et à
faire des des objectifs de l'association
c'était faire des recherches et
transmettre et on transmet comment
faisant des livres à quelques Moots des
Jeux Olympiques le thème de cette année
était tout trouvé la littérature et les
sport c'est d'ailleurs Nelson Montfort
célèbre journaliste sportif qui a été
choisi comme président d'honneur
l'occasion pour lui de présenter ses
derniers livres j'en présente
essentiellement un qui est donc celui
que vous voyez ici mémoires olympiques à
publié chez Michel Lafond mais je suis
heureux d'également d'en présenter un
deuxième qui est le jean ferra que j'ai
publié avec mon confrère et ami Philippe
Laurin Philippe Laurin autre invité
d'exception pour ce salon peintre
illustrateur et dessinateur il exposait
aussi ses peintures lors d'une
exposition une référence à son dernier
livre Les rugbyman de légende c'est
important parce que j'ai de nombreuxes
amis ici et je tenais à venir à leur
manifestation parce que c'est pour moi
une remarquable Maison de la Culture et
c'est nécessaire parmi d'autres un
rendez-vous nécessaire et immanquable
pour certains visiteurs c'est une
habitude depuis que le salon du livre
existe sur encour on y vient chaque fois
je viens toujours au salon du livre qui
est souvent extrêmement passionnant je
suis en train de faire le repérage mais
j'en ai déjà repéré deux ou trois et je
vais probablement acheter près de 400
personnes se sont déplacés pour
rencontrer tous les auteurs les équipes
planent déjà sur la prochaine édition
avec pour thème les
guerres